only from the i-team local dea agents
bust an online drug
ring that was being run right here in
the valley investigators say a
team of men sold cocaine through the
mail
the i-team's david sharon is here now
with what he's uncovered david
ryan denise millions of dollars worth of
cocaine sent right through envelopes
like this one we get right at the post
office
drug agents telling the i-team this is
happening more and more often with the
advent of those crypto currencies
the good thing though is finding these
online stores
it isn't easy four men face
federal charges here in las vegas
accused of using the dark web to sell
cocaine and transferring their proceeds
in cryptocurrency
just a plain google search isn't going
to get you there this dea
agent agreed to talk to the i-team we're
concealing his identity due to his
ongoing work
the dark web sounds like a very scary
place and
oftentimes it can be the dark web
websites where criminals are selling
all things illegal and one where access
is granted only through specific
software
according to court documents
investigators say the four men worked
out of at least
two stash houses across the valley
including this storage unit near
mccarran airport
there the team packed thousands of
orders into priority mail envelopes
sending them right through the postal
service they will go to
extremes to try not to get caught so
they might go to every post office in
the valley and just deliver one package
to not bring
extra attention to themselves but
they're still doing it in a mass volume
one round dropped off here at the post
office on martin luther king boulevard
in north las vegas
the envelopes full of cocaine put right
in the drop box out front
according to court documents in all from
february of last year to the end of this
may
investigators believe the team filled
thousands of orders
totaling more than 40 pounds and netting
nearly 2 million dollars in just four
months alone
satisfied customers even writing reviews
it gets as sophisticated as somebody
actually a drug dealer trying to rate
their site
trying to attract business but business
is now closed
thanks to a months long investigation we
want to help as much as we can to work
with the public
and get information out to people so we
can help prevent things
agents also tell me when they busted
that stash house
three of the four men were actually
packing more cocaine for shipment
at some point somebody tried to flush
some of it down the toilet as well
i'm david charns 8 news now